micah is with us in Little Rock Arkansas
hi Michael welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey thank you how you doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up well I
was kind of wanting to ask the question
of maybe what would you do if you're in
the situation that I'm in I have
accumulated some some cash over the
years in our savings account and I'm
trying to find a safe way to invest it
but but then I'm where I'm getting
better returns and what I'm seeing in
like CDs right now I'm very very
conservative when it comes to money and
through this process I've stumbled
across like triple net leases where say
in Orlando or you know you buy a
restaurant chain and they and they lease
it back immediately after the self or
say seven percent return you know
through the rents isn't that something
that you would recommend is that a safe
way to put money where hopefully the
real-estate appreciates and you're
getting this annual annual rent from it
well you're just buying a piece of
commercial real estate you have an a
tenant and so a triple a tenant and so
you're making what we call a credit
tenant in the in the real estate world
and so they are not willing to pay much
of a cap rate it's called the
capitalization rate which is what you're
actually making on the property which
Whichard Ron what's a 7% cap rate is how
this thing is capped out and so you're
just buying real estate with a super
high-quality tenant with a low rent
that's all it is dollars is that I'm
sorry is that better
so looking like 2 million dollars to
invest if you bought another two million
dollar property that didn't have a
triple a tenant in it but that you could
attract good quality tenants to that pay
you know you might make a 10 cap rate
but what I I'm looking also investing as
little time as possible because I still
I own a business and so I'm doing that
full-time and I just I'm looking for
something better than a CD but something
where I
I invest about that much time then the
cap rate would be fine I mean the triple
a tenant credit tenant situation will be
fine I have never bought one of those
properties personally I've attempted to
a few times but I just demand more of a
rate of return but I own a lot of real
estate and so I own a you know property
management firm that my son-in-law runs
for us as a part of the deal right so
you know I'm set up that way where
you're not and in your case with your
risk aversion and you're not wanting to
have any hassle factor a Triple Net
triple-a credit tenant means that you're
doing no maintenance you're not even
paying the taxes or insurance they're
paying them directly and they send you
proof of payment all they do is send you
the rent that's it and you own the
building and it appreciates now usually
these are long-term leases and so the
downside is is the building is not going
to appreciate as much as other real
estate like it because it is hampered by
this lower rate of return lease it is
also enhanced by this lower rate of
return lease if the buyer is you you
know but that you're you're the type of
buyer and so we're a piece of real
estate goes up in value it that lease
owns that property so if they have a
long-term 20-year lease on it if the
piece of property across the street
sells for triple your value doesn't go
up because that lease has got that thing
encumbered for 20 years you follow me
you're only your value only goes up if
your tenant goes out and then whatever
market goes in now the downside is you
could lease to Sears or Toys R Us your
Circuit City Circuit City yeah exactly
which by the way we're all credit
tenants at one time mm-hmm and they were
all high-low cap rate type tenants and
would have been considered that and I
got a Toys'R'Us sitting about a three
hundred yards from where I'm sitting
right now that's I don't own it but I
mean it's a building sitting over there
empty and and you know that that that
landlord now has a face of property that
is no longer encumbered by the lease
right right
so is there any is there something else
that I'm not aware of where I could put
this money where I could get some use of
it I think I think this is really really
good for you I think you're gonna like
this if you wanna you know if you don't
want to put it all in one property
I wouldn't I'd probably just try this
you know pick you up like if you got two
million dollars to play with picking up
a 1 million dollar deal and then the
next time you do it you might crank it
up another notch up for you in risk
would be a traditional triple net lease
but not a credit tenant and where you'll
find that that is a really you know
probably a full point or two up on your
cap rate in other words you might make
nine instead of seven would be a good
warehouse deal a lot of warehouses are
triple net the tenant takes care of
everything and sends you a check but the
tenant may not be a household name that
is a restaurant chain or Walgreens or
CVS or something like that right which
is just about all of those deals are I
looked at one around the corner here of
Pier one Imports was a triple net our
triple-a credit tenant with a triple net
I looked at a while back about five
years ago I guess I looked at that deal
but anyway that that you can move up by
in cap rate and a slight amount in
hassle with a warehouse scenario and
that might be something to play with as
your next purchase but I think this is
fine purchase for you another one that
people do it's even a lower cap rate is
like a post office because your tenant
is the ultimate credit tenant it's the
US government and so when you have a
federal government as you're the federal
government has your tenant and you've
done a build a suit lease back with a
post office deal you know your cap rate
may be down even lower it might be down
five or four and some change right now
but it's almost like buying T bonds at
that point or t-bills because again
you're there's zero risk of bankrupt
zero risk of bankruptcy so on something
to play with it's interesting
be sure to actually look at the balance
sheet if it's a publicly traded credit
tenant and look at read up on them read
the what people are saying bad about
them how much debt they're carrying what
cash position they're in and those kinds
of things what's happening with their
prop with their with their cash flows
and their profit margins and their
trends and their stock price and you
know just do it you don't have to do a
detailed thing you don't have a master's
degree in finance but just do some
reading and understand get a feel for
how strong this credit tenant is because
there's a there's an away of tenants
that would be considered credit tenants
in other words you would want to smell
that toys-r-us was deeply in debt and if
you had been pitched toys-r-us before it
made the news is being broke or before
they filed bankruptcy the first time
then you go in you say oh my gosh these
people got a lot yeah they've got a lot
then they got no cash there this could
be a problem and you just come it's a
pretty simple thing to look at it so
that's a good that's a good discussion
interesting call I don't think I've ever
had that call it's cool I like talking
about real estate obviously